this week's classic interview is an
interview that I received a ton of
emails about we recently had I don't
know whether to call him evangelical
pastor he's kind of a televangelist I
don't know what to call the guy we have
Ray Comfort on the show and there were
references made during that interview to
my past interviews with him some of
which have been very very compelling so
for this week's classic interview we're
going back to my interview from March of
2014 with Ray Comfort where we talked
about the Hollywood movie Noah and Ray
Comfort as may not come as a surprise to
many in our audience found the movie
disrespectful because of what he felt
were inaccuracies in the movie about the
story of Noah from the Bible I don't
think it needs much more explanation I
don't think it needs much more
introduction this is an interview that I
want a lot of our new people in our sort
of audience universe to check out it was
referenced during last week's interview
with Ray Comfort and it is endlessly
fascinating let's take a look I am
joined once again by Ray Comfort he is
co-host of the TV program the way of the
master it's been a little while since he
was last on the program it's always a
pleasure to have you Ray you know you
and I have had disagreements over the
years about different topics we've
talked about abortion we've talked about
the Bible and gay marriage etc but today
we're talking actually about movies and
about Hollywood and there is of course
the big Hollywood story of Noah but
there's also another know a movie that
is being released you don't particularly
like the Hollywood Noah let's start
there what don't you like about it
well they've got a president of
Hollywood they can make a lot of money
if they just stay true to the Bible when
Cecil B DeMille in 1956 produced the Ten
Commandments it introduced the 12
commandments and dropped the adultery 1
because it made him feel uncomfortable
it was Ten Commandments they stayed true
to Scripture and America loved it it was
the highest Grayson grossing film of
1956 the same with Ben Hur they had
poetic license when all over the place
being her kissing ladies whatever
whatever they want to do that's fine but
when it came to biblical material they
stayed
according to Scripture Jesus wasn't
crucified between two rapists because it
sound better was between two thieves
America loved it 11 Academy Awards
highest-grossing film of 1959 that's the
precedent they can do a Hollywood can
just stay true but the Bible says don't
make it up as you go along what happened
with the latest Russell Crowe version as
they made it up when they went along it
was originally listed as fiction they've
since changed it to adventure and they
had all sorts of things Noah being a
psychopathic drunken guy want to kill
his grandson that I consider landing on
the mountains of Ararat landed on a
beach somewhere so it's just sad they
don't see that they can make a lot of
money by just respecting what we believe
so you've created or you're involved
with an alternative movie which I've
seen the preview for and people can
check that out at Noah the movie dot-com
what's the what's the concept behind the
alternative Noah movie well if they've
got the fake now we've got the real one
we've just gone according to Scripture
and Jesus says in the days of Noah
social appeal with the coming of the Son
of Man in other words in the days of
Noah certain things were happening that
would happen just before the coming of
Christ that's what the Bible teaches
and a Noah's day that was much violence
on the earth means hearts were corrupt
very evil full of wicked imaginations
and there was a great corruption and we
see that in today's society so we took
ten biblical signs of the end of the age
and put them into one movie you know
only God knows the future psychics don't
know the future if they did they don't
move to Las Vegas predict the roll of
the dice and be billionaires living in
mansions but they don't know the future
no we agree on that but you and I both
agreed that psychics are apparently not
a real thing I don't I don't believe in
psychics but I guess my question would
be and this is where we often get bogged
down I'm curious what why you're so
concerned with what you describe as
creative liberties being taken in the
sense that the Bible makes assertions
and you make the assertion that the
Bible tells a literal story but that's
all it is it is merely an assertion and
I know from talking to you that you had
you described when you found Jesus and
started a relationship with Jesus if I
recall correctly you grew up Jewish
originally correct me if I'm
on that that's right yeah but but so
really you're just making an assertion
that you think the Bible story is true
so do you find it offensive that this
note the Hollywood Noah is not telling
the story that you assert to be true no
I find I don't find it offensive I find
it very disappointing okay I don't they
don't get it they their bottom line is
to make money if they want to make money
please Christians by not twisting what
they believe I look I've got a sequel
for you this is what Holly Quinn how do
we can do next they can do a movie
called Muhammad and they can paint
Muhammad as a drunken psychopath and see
how many Muslims line up two by two to
come in and support their movie they
wouldn't do that because they respect
Muslims they know that be serious
repercussions that they did that but
they do it with Jesus Christ they do it
with the Bible they twist things and
change things no big deal it is a big
deal to us and if they want us to
support them we will support them in the
millions if they just stay a true true
according to the scripture that's all
we're asking but do you think ray that
then I'm maybe interpreting what you
just said about the respect for Muhammad
do you think that in the United States
the the Muslim faith is more respected
than Christianity it's more feared it's
certainly more feared in that we have so
much corporate media propaganda making
us scared of Muslims as terrorists but I
don't know if that's what you mean it is
what I mean
Muslims will cut you hit off a few to a
cartoon of Mohammed so so you're saying
they're rightly feared oh I think so
we've got we've got I just have to watch
the news tonight look in the media media
today they are very angry that this
movie is even being made I'm not angry
I'm disappointed I think here is an
opportunity to respect Christians and
and even jews because jews believe the
old testament and just just say what
happen in the bible and i gotta make a
move and they could have their poetic
license have no running around doing
what do you want but but i guess my
question is you using that you said
you're not offended which is good i'm
glad that you're not offended but you
said that it's disrespectful to the
story but again the story itself is only
an assertion and it is not a historical
text
that's your assertion I believe it's an
historical text it happened I believe in
a literal worldwide catastrophic flood I
believe there was a man named Noah who
built an ark we have us genealogy it's
very clear you don't believe I believe
and this is America we can agree to
disagree
no no question about that with with
regard to your movie let's talk about
your movie a little bit okay your movie
in the preview I've not seen the movie
but based on the preview that your
publicist sent me the movie says it will
give you ten prophecies that reveal the
future of the world as well as ten
indisputable signs that we are living in
the last days
Matan yeah absolutely now 60% of
Americans according to the Pew Research
Center think that so-called end times
theories of the the return of the
Messiah apocalypse rapture etc are
totally bogus
so do you think that that's really
palatable right now to the average
American absolutely
that being fed lies by the liberal media
lies about the Bible by atheists across
the country who don't understand
Scripture and don't know the Lord you
are you're saying that the reason 60% of
Americans find the entire concept of
end-times theories to be bogus is
because they've been tricked into
thinking that by the liberal media and
atheists perhaps but I'm not I'm not
impressed by percentages III what
impresses you tell me what impresses you
truth impresses me below Pontius Pilate
had a vote shall we crucify him or not
and the majority said crucify Christ and
it was a wrong thing to do just because
60% say something's true or not true
doesn't change truth if I believe the
Sun comes out at night at square and
it's made of ice don't know what I
believe make it the whole world agree
with me doesn't change realities well
but the immigrants there ray we have to
you and I I know that this is usually
the point in the interview where you
talk about no explanation for the
creation of a blade of grass or a bird
yet that's usually where you go to but I
would be honest if I now hold on a
second right dude hold on a second
you've said that many times I know that
line almost by heart no information for
a blade of grass hold on a second though
well your explanation would be God
created it but the question I'm trying
to get to
is there's a difference between an
assertion about about God for example or
maybe I'm asking you I'll phrase it this
way is there a difference between an
assertion about the creation of the
universe by God and an assertion that
the Sun is Square and made of ice
because one we can observe now and the
other is based on assertions made by men
who wrote the Bible now absolutely wrong
incorrect No so it's the same they're
the same types of assertion absolutely
he assertions the assertion about the
Sun being hot it's axiomatic you don't
make an assertion about it coming out
and in the daytime it comes out and down
as hot and it's the same in the
existence of God it's axiomatic
scientifically there's a creator well
but that's only if you accept that there
was a creation and and that is actually
and your implicit in your statement ray
and I don't know we're not going to I
know we're not going to agree on this
but implicit in your language is the
idea that there was a creation let me
let me change my language and make it a
theistic natures absolute proof there is
a maker nature couldn't create itself a
nature to create itself it had to be
pre-existent to make itself before it
made itself which is scientifically
ludicrous so no no no but this is this
is a logic game that is often played and
it already assumes so many things and it
is kind of wordplay because then we say
well what is nature was we could argue
that nature was even before we had the
colloquial nature on earth that matter
and energy are nature the the entire
idea of what you're presenting ray
assumes that there was what you would
describe as a creation and we don't know
that you don't know it you well how do
you know it because I've got common
sense no it's because you believe God
it's because you assert that God is
right and it is only an assertion ray
okay so we just have to agree to differ
we will we will hit last thing I want to
talk about do you think that maybe we
need to not worry so
much about whether the movies like Noah
stray from what you consider to be the
biblical truth because more and more we
have fewer and fewer people identifying
as religious so for example if you look
at August 2012 the sociology of religion
study from the early 70s to 2012
consistently we see people secularizing
and reducing church attendance is it may
be possible are you open to the idea
that we're at a time in society where
people are just moving away from
religion and are just more interested in
being entertained by noah the movie then
seeing what you might call the biblical
accurate version the more people that
move away from a religion religion the
better religion never helped a soul the
world is full of different religions of
people striving to get right with God by
their own efforts and Christianity God
grants everlasting life to all those who
repent and trust in Jesus
nothing religious about it you don't
have to do good works 10 if do religious
works just repent and trust in Christ
and I'm not worried about no as I say
that I'm disappointed and disrespectful
and disrespected by it yeah well they
need to respect Christians the same way
to respect Muslims okay but so you're
saying you're unconcerned with people
moving away from religion you think oh
no quickly they move away from religion
the better come to Christ repent trust
in him but that blessing like so you say
that Christianity is not a religion is
that weird to say that didn't say that
Christianity is one of the great
religions I'm saying being religious
cannot save a soul any faith in Jesus
can I see what you're saying I see where
you're saying okay good well I think
we've cleared up a lot of things we
didn't agree as we often don't ray I
would encourage my audience to if they
care about these movies at all which I
thought everybody does go see the
Hollywood version go see the one that
you can see it know of the movie calm
and I think people can judge for
themselves right all right very good
Ray Comfort a pleasure is always having
you on good thanks for talking to me
thank you